gossé cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode du coup de fil est à peu près un
mois vous sortir un épisode hashtag
axionov où j'ai parlé des preuves de
l'existence de dieu et j'en ai parlé
comme si croire en dieu ça faisait appel
à la raison enfin si ça fait appel à la
raison il faut absolument que vous parle
du paris basket et ça c'est le pari de
cyrus
alors j'ai déjà parlé de notre ami
pascal dans le troisième coup de fil
mais là on va voir vraiment l'aspect
religieux du personnage c'est parce
qu'il est très très croyant et
d'arriérés passe pas mal de temps avec
des joueurs des joueurs de cartes des
joueurs de paris les choses comme ça
qu'il est beaucoup pour ces travaux pour
réhabiliter tous concourent
mathématicien mais au-delà de ça il va
faire un parallèle entre ces
activités-là donc le jeu et le fait de
croire en dieu envoie il a créé deux
propositions qui sont le fait de croire
en dieu ou de ne pas croire en dieu et
on va conseiller qui a pas d'autre choix
et que tous les individus de la planète
ils rendent forcément dans l'une des
deux catégories pour chaque fois croire
en dieu ou non il s'ensuit des
conséquences par rapport à l'existence
réelle de dieu par exemple si je décide
de croire en dieu et ben je me couper de
certaines choses pour ce dieu par contre
si dieu existe et bin hammam or j'aurai
une récompense éternelle du coup ça nous
donne le tableau suivant
on va poser et si lon comme étant le
kiff que peut apporter une vie sans
obligations religieuses ou la contrainte
que peut infliger une vie religieuse
déjà soit emparé sur l'existence de dieu
soient emparés sur l'inexistence de dieu
et ensuite soit dieu existe soit dieu
n'existe pas dans tous les cas si vous
pariez sur l'existence de dieu et bien
on va dire que votre vie religieuse va
vous donner certaines obligations ou
contrainte et du coup on va mettre moins
epsilon pour toutes les cases
al'inverse si vous pariez sur
l'inexistence de dieu et vous pouvez
faire vraiment ce que vous voulez mais
là on va mettre plus epsilon ensuite si
dieu n'existe pas il ya ni paradis ni en
faire donc quoi de vous croyez et bien
après la mort vous retournez au néant
donc on va mettre de 0,46 dieu existe un
petit peu plus compliqué parce que soit
vous avez cru en lui et dans ce cas là à
dire est que son paradis mon gars tu
gagnes indéfiniment plus l'infini soit
il existe et vous n'avez pas cru en lui
et dans ce cas la direction l'enfer ou
perdez indéfiniment mois infini alors on
utilise epci là parce que epsilon
mathématiques c'est pour des valeurs qui
sont très faibles donc on considère que
le kiff ou la contrainte de la vie
religieuse et ben c'est rien du tout par
rapport à l'or après ce pareil ça n'a de
sens que si on se dit que soit tu
décides de croire en dieu
soit tu décides de ne pas croire en dieu
paradis
je suis désolé j'étais à une soirée
orientale quand c'est arrivé que c'est
tout fait ou se forme à remplir ce
formulaire vous remplissez ce formulaire
et vous revenez aux biches et commence
ici je les ai vus mais c'est jusqu'à
ceni main de l'autre commencé à saigner
un niveau très bas en fait acheté à
l'agglo stick une fête chien fait un
choix est assumé le comme tout le monde
rogère on fait quoi les admis ce tic la
paradis en faire alors on va vous avez
de la chance en plus on se chie sinon
rendue eh ben non c'est à dire pourquoi
oui parfois non
le truc c'est que si on reprend le pari
de pascal s'est logiquement plus
intéressant de croire en dieu parce que
si je crois en dieu soit je me goure et
dans ce cas là bas j'ai moins epsilon
soit j'ai raison et j'ai plus l'infini
alors que si je décide pas croire en
dieu bas soit j'ai raison et j'ai plus
epsilon soit g t ag - d'infiniti donc le
pire si je crois en dieu c'est moi et
pilonnent non mais le sahara est
d'insister je ferai pas l'amour à toi et
à tous tes amis j'ai décidé de vivre une
chaste et si je crois pas en dieu c'est
moins infinie je crois que c'est mieux
d'éviter d'infinies fois que c'est mieux
croire en dieu en fait tout que
bizarrement c'est pas aussi simple un
mec qui n'est pas croyant tue pas le
convaincre accès d'arguments alors qu'à
priori est logique et mathématique
du coup pascal il se rend compte que
c'est pas être la raison que tu peux
croire en dieu et c'est d'ailleurs lui
qui est l'auteur de la citation le coeur
a ses raisons que la raison ignore
et là tout ce qui avait un skyblog on me
demandait le rapport mais le rapport ce
que quand parce qu'elle dise à eybens le
coeur c'est la foi la foi en dieu donc
le coeur a ses raisons que la raison
ignore c'est à dire que la foi et la
raison sont deux choses séparées et donc
il suffit pas d'un argument logique
pourquoi rendu donc ça n'a rien à voir
avec vos histoires d'amour bonjour je
vois ce que je veux voir une vidéo de
cyrus north est en fait nous tatouage
sait pas vraiment ce que je voulais dire
ouais j'ai fait un peu porte-voix après
dans la lignée du paris pascal plus tôt
avant lui il ya le moins connu pareille
de marc aurèle en lui c'est simple il
dit vit une bonne vie bonne danseuse de
bien au niveau des valeurs
donc soit il ya des dieux et s'il ya des
dieux c'est qu'ils sont juste dans ce
cas là ils vont te juger en fonction de
tes valeurs de la victime n'est est pas
envie d'ajouter croyances hockey soit
n'ya pas de dieu et dans ce cas là c'est
pas grave tu as vécu une bonne vie et tu
restera dans la mémoire de tes amis
soit il ya des dieux mais ils sont
injustes et ils valent pas la peine
d'être vénérée voilà assez marc aurèle
c'est un stoïcien évidemment le pari de
pascal ça ne marche que si tu considères
que c'est parce que tu crois pas en dieu
que tu vas forcément en enfer et vice
versa d'ailleurs on pouvait faire un
pareil sur ma chaîne c'est très simple
il suffit de s'abonner
voilà et moi je vous garantis le plus
l'infini vous envoie du love et de la
piste ouais j'espère que le pari de
pascal s'est pas non plus car pour vous
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est la
démarche de pascal derrière tout ça
c'est à dire que montrer que voilà c'est
la raison et la croyance et de choses
qui sont vraiment c'est pareil
n'hésitez pas à voir ma dernière vidéo
sur les cinq profs des licences de dieu
qui est dans la description et de voir
la vidéo sur nietzsche et le
christianisme notamment doit être par là
n'hésitez pas à rejoindre sur facebook
pour des news qui soit relatif à mon
actu ou à l'actu en général soit arrivée
sur twitter pour tout ce que j'aimais
pas sur facebook il ya beaucoup de
choses que j'ai l'impression toujours et
mons à fiat
un petit peu plus perso donc voilà un
vrai plaisir